je cherche un bon avocat c'est pour
défendre une innocente elle s'appelle
josetteette de quoi la question de
meurtre fait voir ce lessin joseette
vous avez dit quel âge a-t-elle 11 ans
elle m'a entendu plaider dans l'affaire
Grondin je suis confiant elle s'est dit
que j'était celui qui pouvait sauver cet
enfant coupable vous savez qu'être
avocat c'est sauver son client he pas le
faire
condamner une enfant de 11 ans accusé à
tort c'est imperdable l'quitement sera
une formalité
l'accusé non mais je rêve ils l'ont
misise dans une cage pauvre
enfant vous m'avez engagé pour défendre
une chèvre une chèvre oui Majesté une
chèvre
ben tous les autres avaient dit non bien
sûr faudrait être un anâne pour accepter
de défendre une
chèvre vous ne saviez pas que l'accusé
était une chèvre bien sûr que si il y a
quelques instant vous sembliez plutôt
surpris j'ai bien vu votre tête vous AZ
fait oh je l'ai jamais fait oh vous êtes
parti la tête en arrière avec votre
paillasse là qui vous sert de quoi
coiffure je sens que la vérité est là
toute proche mais qu'avez-vous vu j'ai
tout vu
tout pour moi c'est plus qu'une
chèvre c'est ma meilleure amie c'est ma
sœur ma confidante oui allons-y ma mère
aussi par
con